then you did it with t how about warlock
uh no i i knew warlock from the comedy
store from just smoking cigs and
drinking budweisers on the front patio
if you would describe warlock's body
who's warlock warlock these people you
don't know what warlocks are dude or
rick and i go from the medieval age of
warlocks
yeah we had a different time man warlock
was like uh he was the accountant for
the house of blues
never i would have never guessed an
account a warlock would be the account
that's all i'm going to say yeah real
name
cigarette jeremy imagine that's name
cigarette smoke in human form yeah oh
god that's warlock
yes
it's actually made up of ash yeah that's
a good way of doing it yeah ash and
ciggies also a great dude but just
definitely where you're just like i'm
getting cancer right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah also you know all those terms like
you're greasy dude you know what i mean
that's all derived from warlock
mimicking no just like all those words i
feel like he came up with by hanging out
with warlock so warlock holly yeah yeah
polly yeah so warlock was this greasy
dude but back then it's like um but one
time
polygons
i was this girl was blowing me mm-hmm
and polygons after she was done
and i felt this i've never had my heart
break
it was so hard
i remember this story yeah yeah it put
it breaks my heart so she's just poor
girl she's 22.
june you're in
no i must have been at the time 28
and she's done and she's you know she's
wiping the come off
oh she blew you to completion oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've never successfully
done that yeah but i was younger the gun
was new i feel like the gun was way
newer
yeah yeah
you're trick or whatever loser you're
causing
issues now with this no he is
i tried so hard for his birthday
i understand that i understand that and
i said i would jerk off the rest
stop and he was like
i'll take it from here but her she took
an hour
oh i would have given you an hour after
20 minutes i was like your 50th birthday
i would have no no you were sweating
your hands were wet it was terrible
like yeah so anyway that's dedication so
she's poker she blows me and she's done
and i want to go you want to go have
breakfast or whatever because i always
like to do that yeah you're so sweet so
sweet and she goes
below him did
she looks at her to blow warlock
yeah right and my heart went
and did she yeah
and i had breakfast on my own
that's the real sad part
of it that's the sad part yeah yeah
still i'm still getting breakfast yeah
yeah and so she did that and broke my
heart but so you never got any back then
no i never got any and then there's like
one time i was in uh
i think i was in like dayton ohio or
something
and
uh caparillo was with us
and uh my best friends after the show
someone goes uh
someone girls were talking to cap and
the cat was like hey these girls want to
go
uh want us to meet him at this club and
i'm like oh all right
thinking like hey maybe this will work
me and cap just the two biggest players
out there
two of the most regular white dudes yeah
yeah yeah and so we we go to this club
and we get there and it's the girls and
their boyfriends and i'm like oh this
makes way more sense that they were just
like on the road friend zoning us yeah
and uh so we hung out for like 10
minutes i'm like dude we got to get the
[ __ ] out of here i don't want to just
hang out with normal people yeah and uh
so then we went back
and
i walked up to my hotel room and i
opened the door and terrell was just
slaying it
all right oh you're working i need to
share a room with them oh my god it just
goes oh man i forgot to lock it sorry
bro and i'm just like
wow yeah and then i walked over to
capparillo's room i'm like hey can i
hang out in here terrell's with that
chick
and he's like big dick oh yeah
yeah i mean frightening
maybe i shouldn't stay in the room
bigger dick than leslie jones
way bigger okay
when trail hit me up later to tell me
that
he was done he was like the text he sent
me was like
bro i'm finished up sorry you had to see
me laying a yard and a half a dick oh
wow that's a cool thing to say yeah yeah
i've never said that out loud before no
[Music]